austria germany and the netherlands are
all seeing surges in coveted infections
and deaths so why isn't that happening
here and can the government really be
confident in sticking to plan a
well a quick glance at the numbers and
you can see why those countries are
considering lockdowns rocketing case
numbers in the netherlands here in dark
blue austria in grey and lightview
germany is now about level with the uk
but cases are rising fast so what's
going on well vaccines could have a lot
to do with it as you can see here the
uk's uptake was faster and started
earlier germany and austria only reached
our levels of coverage in recent weeks
there was also a shorter gap between
doses for much of these countries
rollouts combined that could translate
into lower levels of protection overall
on top of that here we started booster
vaccines over two months ago and the
over 12 started getting jabs last month
the more people you vaccinate the fewer
there are to infect
but timing is probably crucial too let's
look at cases again
infection rates have been kept low in
many parts of europe for a combination
of restrictions through late summer and
autumn in the uk we opened up in july
and we stayed open we're not seeing this
late autumn wave because we've had high
case numbers for months
over the summer months when we were
experiencing a big surge driven by the
more transmissible delta variant they
had very low numbers of cases
we have as a consequence of that wave
over the summer a lot higher natural
immunity and superimpose on that natural
immunity obviously is vaccine-induced
immunity
there's certainly evidence for that look
at covid antibodies in 16 to 24 year
olds in england up at around 96 percent
yet only 84 have had at least one dose
of the vaccine compelling evidence of
natural infection topping up vaccine
protection
so is this an indication of the uk
strategy well let's look at deaths with
a covert infection you can certainly
argue we've avoided a winter surge so
far compared with others but at what
cost for months the uk that's in red has
been averaging 100 to 150 covered deaths
a day since we opened up on july 19th
nearly 15 000 people have died with
covet
on top of that there's the impact of
severe illness and the drain it's
putting on the nhs we're sticking to
plan a but there are many cold winter
months still to come